The body is incredible and taking information from the outside world through
our five senses and making sense of it so that we can respond appropriately.
We're able to do this because of three types of neurons. First, we have sensory
neurons. Sensory neurons receive information from sense organs, for example the
eyes, the tongue or the skin. Everything that we can see, touch, taste or feel
is because of our sensory neurons. So the sensory neurons send sensory
information to our brain and spinal cord. Take this for example, when I saw
Sputnik, the sensory neurons in my eyes were firing. When I was petting him,
the sensory neurons in my skin were firing because I could feel how soft he
was. The sensory neurons send the message to the brain where the brain
processes it. The motor neurons carry commands from our brains to our muscles
to allow us to act appropriately. So my motor neurons allowed me to bend down
and pet Sputnik. Finally, we have the Interneurons. The interneurons connect
the neurons to other neurons. Some interneurons connect sensory neurons to
motor neurons, or else some interneurons connect to neurons in the brain.
Interneurons outnumber our sensory and our motor neurons, 10 to 1. So that's
right, sensory neurons are responsible for all the incoming information that
goes to our brain. Our brain interprets it and our motor neurons allow us to
carry out appropriate behaviors. Our interneurons connect motor neurons to
sensory neurons and also neurons to parts of the brain.
&gt;&gt; Thanks Susan, you want to give them a quiz on this?
&gt;&gt; Yes. Let's quiz.